[Musique]
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui dans science
clic les mathématiques de la relativité
générale parti si ce flux d'énergie
[Musique]
notre univers consiste en un tissu
l'espace temps dans lequel est déposé un
contenu désastre de la masse de
l'énergie à première vue le contenu de
l'univers semble très diversifié on y
trouve des étoiles des planètes des
nuages de gaz interstellaires ou encore
des êtres vivants comme nous pourtant
toute cette diversité peut être résumé
en un seul et unique concept des
mouvements d'énergie
l'énergie est une notion abstraite qui
traduit la présence de perturbation dans
l'univers en particulier il peut s'agir
de matière de masse la masse contient de
l'énergie d'après la formule e égal mc2
mais d'autres facteurs contribuent eux
aussi au contenu énergétique de
l'univers comme le champ
électromagnétique ou encore l'énergie
sombre qui à la fameuse propriété d'être
négative sous toutes ses formes cette
énergie va se déplacer dans l'espace
temps à la façon d'un fluide
le mouvement de notre pomme par exemple
peut être synthétisés comme un flux
d'énergie pour décrire un tel flux
d'énergie
intéressons nous à un point sur sa
trajectoire
à partir de ce point l'énergie va
communiquer son mouvement dans
différentes directions sur notre feuille
à deux dimensions
le mouvement peut se propager à travers
quatre surfaces 2 pour chacune des deux
corps donné qu'on utilise mais la
situation est symétrique par exemple si
l'énergie communique son mouvement
depuis le passé il doit ressortir vers
le futur ainsi seuls deux surfaces sont
nécessaires pour décrire entièrement la
façon dont s'échangent les mouvements
d'énergie
si la pomme reste immobile dans l'espace
elle communique son énergie uniquement
vers le futur ainsi seule la surface
associer autant va être traversés par un
flux de mouvement et si la pomme se
déplace dans l'espace elle va
communiquer son énergie à travers
chacune des deux surfaces pour chaque
surface représentons le flux du
mouvement d'énergie qui la traversent
par un vecteur en fonction du
comportement de l'énergie comme une
sorte de fluides
ces vecteurs vont varier en les des
composants sur les vecteurs de base on
va pouvoir créer un tableau à partir de
ces deux vecteurs
ce danseur traduit les échanges de
mouvements au sein de l'énergie on le
note grant et c'est ce qu'on appelle le
temps soeur énergie compulsion dans
notre temps soeur la première case
mesure la quantité d'énergie qui
traverse le temps au cours du temps
cette case correspond donc à la quantité
d'énergie qui reste immobile dans
l'espace qui ne se déplace que vers le
futur on l'appelle plus communément la
densité d'énergie
elle est d'autant plus grande que le
point et danse en énergie les deux cases
qui suivent sont égales toutes deux
représente la quantité de mouvement qui
va être transmise à l'énergie au cours
du temps ces cases mesurent la vitesse
spatiale de l'énergie son mouvement dans
l'espace au cours du temps
[Musique]
leur valeur va être d'autant plus grande
que l'énergie se déplacent rapidement
dans l'espace par rapport au temps on
appelle ces cases la densité d'impulsion
car elle mesure la quantité de
mouvements de l'énergie
enfin la dernière case du tableau mesure
la composante spatiale du flux d'énergie
à travers l'espace à première vue cette
case est plus difficile à interpréter
car il faut donner un sens à cet échange
de mouvements dans l'espace
il s'agit en fait d'une tendance que va
avoir l'énergie a poussé dans une
direction
c'est ce qu'on appelle plus communément
la pression dans notre exemple à deux
dimensions
le tableau ne contient que quatre cases
dont deux sont identiques mais dont
notre univers à quatre dimensions ce
tableau contient en réalité 16 cases on
retrouve la densité d'énergie
c'est-à-dire la quantité d'énergie qui
reste conservés dans le temps la densité
d'impulsion qui est cette fois-ci
décomposée en trois cases pour chaque
dimension des espaces la pression qui
est elle aussi décomposé sur les trois
dimensions mais également des nouveaux
termes qui correspond aux flux de
viscosité la viscosité est la tendance
que va avoir l'énergie a communiqué un
mouvement parallèle autour d'elle
il est important de comprendre que les
composantes de ces flux de mouvements
des pontes du système de coordonnées
qu'on a choisi lorsqu'on change de
coordonner une énergie immobile peut
devenir une énergie en mouvement
cela correspond simplement à dire que le
mouvement d'un objet est relatif il
dépend du point de vue depuis lequel on
observe pour illustrer ce concept de
tenseur énergie impulsion nous allons
nous pencher sur deux exemples standard
le premier exemple est celui d'un espace
temps vide
lorsqu'on l'expriment en un point qui
n'est traversée par aucune énergie le
temps soeur énergie impulsion nuls
toutes ces cases val 0 ce cas très
simple et pourtant fondamental car si
celui qu'on utilisera le plus souvent en
effet lorsqu'on souhaite décrire le
mouvement d'un petit objet à travers
l'espace temps par exemple un satellite
autour de la terre ou une pomme à
proximité d'un trou noir
on peut négliger la masse de ce petit
objet qui est très faible par rapport à
la masse de l'astre on considère alors
que l'objet se situe dans un endroit
vide et le temps soeur énergie impulsion
nuls
le deuxième exemple concret représente
le cas où l'on s'intéresse à des
mouvements à l'intérieur d'un astre par
exemple on peut vouloir décrire le
mouvement d'un objet à l'intérieur du
soleil
dans ce cas même en négligeant la masse
de notre petit objet celui ci ne se
situe toujours pas dans le vide car on
ne peut pas négliger la matière qui
forment le soleil
dans un tel cas le temps sur nrj
impulsion n'est pas nul
et ces valeurs sont plus ou moins
complexes en fonction de la structure du
fluide
si on considère que la masse du soleil
forme un fluide parfait sans viscosité
et à l' équilibre alors le temps soeur
ne contient qu'une densité d'énergie
liée à la masse du soleil et une
pression diriger vers l'extérieur qui
lui permet de ne pas s'effondrer sur lui
même
[Musique]